you're exceptionally good at debate uh
you uh you wrote how to debate leftists
and Destroy them uh you're kind of known
for this kind of stuff just
exceptionally skilled the conversation I
debate uh at getting to the facts of the
matter and using logic to get to the to
the conclusion uh in the debate do you
ever worry that this power
talk about the ring
this power you were given has corrupted
you and your ability to see what's like
to to pursue the truth versus just
winning debates I hope not I mean so I
think one of the things that that's kind
of funny about The Branding versus the
reality is that most of the things that
get characterized as destroying in
debates with facts and logic
um most of those things are basically me
having a conversation with somebody on a
college campus it actually isn't like a
formal debate where we sit there and we
critique each other's positions or it's
not me insulting anybody a lot of the
clips that have gone very viral is me
making an argument and then they're not
being like an amazing counter argument
many of the debates that I've held have
been extremely cordial let's take the
latest example like about a year ago I
debated Anna kasparian from Young Turks
it was very cordial it was very nice
right
um you know that's it that that's sort
of the way that I like to debate my rule
when it comes to debate and or
discussion is that my opponent actually
gets to pick the mode in which we work
so if it's going to be a debate of ideas
and we're just going to discuss and
critique and clarify y then we can do
that if somebody comes loaded for bear
then I will respond in kind because one
of the big problems I think in sort of
the debate slash discussion sphere is
very often misdiagnosis of what exactly
is going on people who think that a
discussion is debate and and vice versa
and that can be a real problem and there
are people who
you know
treat what ought to be a discussion as
for example in exercise and performance
art and so what that is is mugging or
trolling or saying trolley things in
order to just get to the like that's
something I actually don't do during
debate I mean if you actually watch me
talk to people I don't actually do the
trolling thing the trolling thing is
almost solely relegated to Twitter and
me making drugs on my show when it comes
to actually debating people that sounds
actually a lot like what we're doing
right now it's just the person maybe
taking just an obverse position to mine
uh and so that's that's fine usually
half the debate or discussion is me just
asking for clarification of terms like
what exactly do you mean by this so I
can drill down on where the actual
disagreement May lie because some of the
time people think they're disagreeing
and they're actually not disagreeing
right like when I'm when I'm talking
with Anna kasparian and she's talking
about corporate and government have too
much power together I'm like well you
sound like a tea party like you and I
are on the same page about that that
sort of stuff does tend to happen a lot
in discussion
um I think that when when discussion
gets termed debate it's a problem when
debate gets term discussion it's it's
even more problematic because debate is
a different thing and I find that your
debate and your conversation is often in
good faith you're able to steal man on
the other side you're able to actually
you're actually listening you're
considering the other side the times
when I see that you you know Ben Shapiro
destroys leftist it's usually just like
you said the other side is doing the
trolling
um because they've I mean the people
that do criticize you
uh for that interaction is the people
that usually get destroyed are like 20
years old and they're usually not
sophisticated in any kind of degree uh
in terms of being able to use logic and
reason and facts and so on and that's
that's totally fine by the way I mean if
people want to criticize me for speaking
on college campuses where a lot of
political conversation happens both
right and left that's fine I mean I've
had lots of conversations with people on
the other side of the aisle too I mean
right I've done podcasts with Sam Harris
and we've talked about atheism or I've
done debates with Anna kasparian or I've
talked to I've done debate with
chankweiger or I've I've had
conversations with lots of people on the
other side of the aisle in fact I
believe I'm the only person on the right
who recommends that people listen to his
shows on the other side of the aisle
right I mean I say on my show on a
fairly regular basis that people should
listen to pod save America now no one on
positive America will ever say that
somebody should listen to my show that
is verboten that is not something that
can be had it's one of the strangenesses
of our politics it's what I've called
the happy birthday problem which is I
have a lot of friends who are of the
left and are publicly of the left and on
my birthday they'll send you a text
message happy birthday but they will
never tweet happy birthday lest they be
acknowledging that you were born of
woman and that this can't be allowed so
on the Sunday special I've had a bevy of
people who are on the other side of the
aisle a lot of them ranging from people
in Hollywood like Jason Blom to Larry
Wilmore to
Sam to you know just a lot of people on
the left I think we're in the near
future probably going to do a Sunday
special with rokana up in California the
California Congress person very nice guy
I had him on the show like that kind of
stuff is is fun and interesting
um but um you know I think that the easy
way out for a clip that people don't
like is to either immediately clip the
clip it's like a two minute clip and
clip it down to 15 seconds where
somebody insults me and then that goes
viral which is you know welcome to the
internet uh or uh or to say well you're
only debating colleges you're only
talking to 20 I mean I talk to a lot
more people than that that's just not
the stuff you're watching